one of my uh well my regular therapist
suggested I look up these um not for me
not about me but was like you should
look up these personality disorders and
I was and I was like oh man this is
cathartic yeah this makes me feel
not so crazy yeah it was very very nice
it just helps you create some definition
yeah you know exactly right let me say
it's a little clearer what you've been a
great friend to me when I've gone
through it I want to say that for other
people to know I just want to say thank
you that's it what oh
yeah that's it that's all
that's all yeah just that well because
you ended it with I just wanted you to
know I was like Oh I thought you were
going to say like and my love but uh
yeah you're and you and you for me you
know I've Had My Moments uh you were
actually
it's funny because now
so for the folks at home I had a
relationship years ago with this woman
who who
broke your heart that's a no well no I
broke her heart that's fair I broke the
[__] out of her heart that's fair very
very terribly and then the table's
turned and I you know I was like you're
on the other end I was on the other end
and it was deserved but in that pain in
that anguish that I was going through
you you were there and you were such a
good [__] talker and you said some
things that really made me laugh yeah
and um yeah yeah I I am friends with uh
other exes and I really wish I could be
friends with that one now because she
was [__]
looking back she was so awesome yeah she
was
I I in in what I'm going through now as
I'm getting older and
looking for wife future wife as I call
her future wife no no no no but uh am I
talking too much you're talking a lot
let's just be clear when Ben is saying
I'm a good little [__] talker Ben would
be down and you know I just fire off
some jokes I'd chat some [__] yeah and I
get them chuckling and I try to get him
to see hey man it's what else whatever
yeah yeah yeah whatever for sure
um what that was the whitest for sure
for sure uh absolutely now that he's not
capping here folks no no no hat here no
no no no uh
that's hat brother that's oh that is
such hat
uh your honor uh as my nephew would say
that's that's hat that man is full of
brim
his eyes well below his brim yeah you
can't even see those things anyway uh as
I'm as I'm you know going through
realizing what red flags are and green
flags are for what uh what you want in a
partner yeah I'm looking back our green
flag oh yeah yeah for sure lighting your
house on fire green flag yeah yeah uh
very good I I'm like oh man there were
just these things that I'm realizing
again like just the big one that I keep
coming back to is conscientiousness yeah
that is such a big one for for both
people you want to be with someone who's
conscientious who who uh who um because
I remember when I was with her
and I was dealing with an acute kind of
OCD thing at the time she took it upon
herself to like read up on it and learn
wow and and uh be on so she could better
understand me yeah and not rush to
judgment or anything like that great
quality it's such a great quality it is
such an admirable quality and she
celebrated me in in all sorts of ways
and
you know
she got what she deserved
in in an affirm in affirmative way she's
married to a [__] from what I can
tell a super great guy who like you know
treats her well and does all that good
[__] yeah you were you were maybe a
young whippersnapper at that point you
couldn't couldn't appreciate oh I'm
still so young yeah yeah
dude
well you know what one of the thing that
I have to kind of accept is sometimes
you don't get
um sometimes you don't get the like uh
I don't know what the word is closure
that you need yeah in something and you
just kind of have to it can be crazy
making to be like what the [__] was this
and they and you just have to kind of
all right you know what
yeah
yeah I think that that's a
that's something we convince ourselves
of all the time I think we all think we
can control
everything or at least try to affect our
reality into uh something that we can
digest you know like closure but yeah no
you don't you don't always get it and
that's life yeah I think
uh the
I think that's the sooner in life that
you can accept that like
things are just up and down and uh
like if you can just accept like yeah
right now [__] is not cool and it's just
gonna be that until it's not just sounds
obvious but
uh then I think you don't it doesn't
hurt so bad when [__] happens good I
think we were all kind of conditioned to
have expectations yeah there is uh I
might have mentioned it on here before
excuse me but there is
an old
Parable what the [__] do you call I
don't know yeah the guy's got like a
[__] donkey or something and this
other guy comes up to him and goes wow
you're so lucky you got this donkey and
he says yeah maybe and then the next day
uh like the the [__] donkey dies and
the guy another the same guy comes up to
and says well that's so unlucky and he
says yeah maybe and then the next day
because his donkey's dead he didn't go
on this like trip where the [__] road
got flooded and everybody died and the
guy said wow you're so lucky your donkey
died so you didn't go on that trip and
he says yeah maybe and it's just you it
goes back and forth between
oh this thing that appears to be bad is
actually just neutral and this thing
that is good is actually neutral in all
of this [__] so yeah man I'm just
waiting for the [__] point
I want to know where I'm at in the oh
yeah maybe maybe may I know where I am
I'm [__] fine that's you know that's
that's what's agitating is
before with with uh with
very very long ago ex-wife
I was like what the [__] am I doing
where am I going and now I'm in this
place where I'm like
I know where I'm going I know what I'm
doing I got a little money in my pocket
I'm like in the best shape I've ever
been in I'm
I'm ready for the thing yeah I think
you're
right now as an observer to me it sounds
like
you're pinning too much of your identity
to what's going on in your life I was
actually talking with I talked with
Spock a lot about this and he is
actually he's kind of helped me form
this thought but basically
I used to tie a lot of I think my
personal existence to like the concept
of like what I like a comedian is or
like a performer sure right and if if
I'm not
angling everything I'm doing towards
being this thing than like what's the
point of what I'm doing like it's like I
I'm almost using some like archetype of
a
like this definition of a person it's
like I'm just trying to live up to that
definition like what's going on in your
life whether it's positive negative and
if it's working towards something or not
it doesn't make you lesser than or it
doesn't make you not a whole sure oh I
don't feel that way at all okay all
right all right thank you I feel great
okay good I feel very fulfilled and I
feel there's actually I was I just
realized um I did mushrooms in the
desert a few uh months ago and if you
can Google please icky guy icky guy
i-k-i-g-a-i it is a it is a Japanese
concept and I had it saved on my
computer for years because I was looking
at this and I'm like how what's my
what is going to be mine my version of
this icky guy is this Japanese concept
of like
um I don't know like finding yourself uh
yeah yeah you're you're yeah the origin
uh Jesus Christ I can't read that I
thought you got Lasik it's
it's just it's this it's yeah it's it's
what gets you up every morning and keeps
you going but that's not the it's not
the best
thing that I've seen but it's this it's
these concentric circles it's this big
Venn diagram of like four different
things melding it's like meaning uh
social utility all of that scroll down
if you um
if you're listening imagine like your
friend who found out they were like uh
um
you know Irish or something and then
they got like a Celtic tattoo it does
look like a Celtic that's what this
looks like yeah but it's got words in it
you've got passion uh here go to go to
images a reason for being there you go
so it's it's the mix of a passion a
mission a profession a vocation right
what the world needs what you're good at
what you love what you can be paid for
right and I realized
whoa I finally achieved that nice dude
and it feels very good congrats in many
ways and different things that I'm that
I'm doing that I'm working on and I feel
very fulfilled and very very content and
very happy that's where I'm at and it's
it's great
um
and it's just yeah it's it's on Maslow's
how you've heard of Maslow's hierarchy
of needs you know the one just the one
element that I'm missing is that let's
see is that
this is me just trying to make you laugh
yeah I know that's Maslow it's like yeah
it's like uh basic needs food and water
yes shelter shelter
and then you know uh career right
[__]
and I I recently met someone
with a vagina with a vagina yeah true
and uh you know I'm
I'm pumped but I'm like cautiously
pumped I'm like all right you know let's
take our time let's do our thing yeah
and who knows yeah
looks good dude yeah